[Music]
the purpose of learning is so it's just
aligned with the purpose of living I
don't think has a purpose I think
learning happens so the purpose of
learning for me I think and it's it's
very basic it's about growing your level
of self-awareness so you know better who
you are so you know better how you do
and then can impact the world but when
you really learn it is when you do it as
an act of freedom you need to be a
responsible citizen and to be a
responsible citizen you need to have a
firm grasp of you know the issues that
are surrounding you whether it's you
know what's going on in your community
what's going on in the world and you
know a lot of these things might have
some basis in science or art or
literature and you can sort of learn
about all these different areas from
very different inputs good powerful
meaningful learning occurs when the
interest of the learner is much with the
capacity of a tutor so the basic idea is
you learn well what you're interested in
learning the purpose of learning is a
very big question one way in which I
think about it is that and I think it
comes from my background as a biologist
one of the fundamental features of all
living things is that you change over
time right and to stay still to in
chemical terms or biochemical terms to
reach equilibrium is to die so so living
things are always in a process of change
they're always in a dynamic state and
ultimately I think learning is almost
the engine that allows us to continue to
be down
so you know I want to separate the
question of learning from the question
of how we as a society as a culture as
institutions define both the kind of
learning that matters the kind of
learning that we should measure the kind
of learning that becomes a threshold for
all the things and the kind of learning
that gives you a reward within the
context of the institution you need
communication skills you need reasoning
skills you need to develop your creative
skills and 4x in Lehigh specifically
learning is about getting the getting at
this at that academic foundation that's
going to prepare you to move on to
post-secondary learning but it's also
developing a world perspective so quite
often when we think about learning and
if we think about learning in the
digital environment the temptation is to
think that learning is a single sort of
definition but ultimately from one field
to another field broadly speaking the
aspiration for learning can be quite
different the best way the most
efficient way in the most powerful way
to sort of decide what should be learned
is is to ask the learners